so we had today something happen which
happens every couple of months which is
at the very very last second a guest
uh no shows cancels on us and that's
a really sad thing or happy depending on
your perspective because instead we'll
get to hear from a few people
in our audience right now via discord
the discord is at davidpakman.com
discord it's a great discord it's a good
discord and we love it let's go first
just to see what's on folks minds let's
go to
desmond from south carolina desmond you
were on the air what's going on
hello can you hear me yes i can how's it
going david uh i really appreciate your
show
haven't tuned in uh recently but um
let me catch my breath please
all right um so uh
i've been noticing a lot with uh
conservative friends and family around
me
gosh
that's weird you're running a marathon
there desmond
no i mean uh you know this is the first
time for me so gotcha gotcha
you're doing great i appreciate it uh
i've i went out to eat with my grandma
no conservative
and we were noticing how here in south
carolina there's a lot of places that
are
they're like hiring and um and some
places are like uh
my grandma was saying oh it's because
all these people are too lazy because uh
they're getting all this welfare
right unemployment and it just made me
it triggered
a thing of me that made me realize well
you know an economics class this is kind
of like a perfect moment to raise
minimum wage
and uh i just don't get why
conservatives aren't really talking
about that kind of basic economic stuff
well because a lot of people and listen
this is conservatives and liberals
everybody does this to some degree um
you
identify a symptom and then you say
it's a symptom that proves my politics
are the right ones
so on the left people see hey there's
jobs remaining unfilled
it's because the wages are too low raise
the minimum wage
why because the left already wants to
raise the minimum wage on the other hand
the right
which doesn't want to raise the minimum
wage but wants to end welfare sees jobs
going unfilled and they say
well you've got to reduce welfare it's
too cushy
to stay at home you know the the truth
is we're in kind of a unique situation
right now because of the pandemic
where enhanced unemployment has made it
so that there are people who otherwise
would have no choice but to go and get a
job
who have been able to stay on
unemployment earning
a little more than they normally would
it's ending in september and as i've
said before
most people want to work most people
derive
meaning from being involved in something
and not just from sitting at home
any welfare system will have free riders
but if it's properly calibrated you
don't have to worry about that
i think this is going to resolve itself
in september october november okay yeah
i didn't know about um
all this ending in september it was just
interesting to me because i noticed the
unemployment number
getting slowly back down to that four
percent that speed spot you know
but still like uh and i noticed other uh
states
actually when i looked into it are
actually resolving the issue
quite well where they easily uh
how do you say um they they just adapt
and they're like okay well we'll pay you
more
but there's a lot of places here even
like bigger businesses like um
dealerships are having troubles hiring
people because our you know our
minimum wage in south carolina is 7.25
so right yeah i think that this is going
to look very different in october
okay i really appreciate it david all
right thanks desmond great call
from south carolina love it